今月は
未だに
蘇武気がします
肇社長の部屋ですいえ私は肇社長なんですけども強度どうぞはじめ冊お部屋に関する
動画です愛カールずこの部屋には何かがいるのではないかと疑って仕方ありませんやー
やっぱ寒いんだよなさあ見て感が強いんだよな普通にこの部屋には姉の何かを感じ
るって言われたり高い色形状車でしたんですけどもう今に甲をしっかりと何かをつかめ
たことはなくそれでもやっぱりこの部屋にはなぜかものすごい
何かがあるそれが何かがちょっとわからないんですけど絶対にダメだって本当になんで
誰も教えてくれないのでなんか動画のネタだからなんかしてんだろうみたいな数よる
ドアのでたですけど今日のぬんですけど本当に何かそれを感じるでそしていろんな人に
はの部屋はおかしいって言われてるんで色々調べたんですけど
霊障っていうものがありましてそれがその辺にあるかと
ぞ+しかめる方法があるみたいです用意するものはこちら
あ
はしばしって何だろうって感じなんですけどなんか徐々に和風のなんかは生の神だと
思います
わかんないですけどあとはお米ですまあそうだなこの2つだけでその部屋に霊がいるか
いないか確かめていきたいとおもいます
この講演者が米通る苦手なんだうーんじゃあやんなって話ですけどまぁそろそろ
ちゃんと見つけたよあみなさんにその霊的なもの
やり方はいたって簡単でこの和紙の上にお米を載せますこれで誰本に書いてあったから
だがガチっぽかったすけ後輩に乗りました
でもとのお米の色を覚えておきますよね max ちょっと写真だけ撮ってきます
これであとは簡単ですこういう感じですねこれ風で撮っ米をは住んで包んでおきますね
これの使用者が囚人する前に
それを一緒にお部屋に置いておきまして次の日の朝お米の様子を開けてみますそしてお
米の色が茶色というかちょっと色が変色していたらその部屋は
ちょっとヤバいとそういう結果になってしまいます下に何もなければ何もないのかな
これはですね本に載ってたやつで割とで何か信憑性があるというか割と信じてますよね
もう夜遅いのでこれと一緒に問題の部屋て出て行こうと思います
やっぺえなんか今日まずでヤバイ気がすんだよね今日はちょっと迂闊で強い7大丈夫か
なぁなんかですじゃあね防府
おまけ立ち返ってみましょう白い場所でお米を包み就寝時枕もっとまあケラーの近くに
車からの近くに置いておきましょうで一晩でもう変色するらしいです
実はこの場を枕元に置いておきますいやー濃い皿頭に救いの手だからねじゃあ幕
本当に失礼します
おやすみなさい
チャボでるネ俺ん3
聞こえただろうか
彼のは誰もの上に怪しい物音が聞こえた
彼のいびきに共鳴するように何かが動いている
とっち超えた
うるさ入りビキニ待機列
急冷が
した移しているように聞こえるのだ
[音楽]
にこの後
信じられない音が聞こえるのだ
和太鼓のような音が聞こえ
対抗の達人だろうか
完全に太鼓の達人である
その後もこの部屋では
変な音が耐え月超え続けたのであった
そして
にゃっ
me
me ん
持ってもうあああう
ran
大丈夫じゃないようだ
うーん確かに腕したらいいん
派遣しがっ
カレーは
初音ミクちゃんの目覚ましに起こされ
噂を迎えたの道路グッズです
あおはようございます何かねいつもより寝る時が進むというわけで一晩たってこれの中
の色がどうなっているでしょうか
見てみます猫
じゃバイ
わからん
me
teame
car
me
あっはぁ
でだってこれわかんなくね所写真を撮ったんですけど
比較してみましょうはいいまいちわかりません5カメラの設定と部屋の光も一緒にした
んですけど
なんかねえ何だろうよくわかんねーなんかもっとわかりやすい何かあればいいですけど
ねこの部屋には鈴がありますみたいなそういうのがあったらよかったらコメント欄でを
付け下さい
3度寝していきます